[Music]
in no nudes till 18 News whoa a little
teens submitted by bring back at the
fails all but then we can talk about
nasty stuff here so it's like almost
like as the fields just kidding news
cheer or subscribe to our pornhub
account don't get bit more credit to
stay and stay here don't go there oh
we're not Jake one more shake you poor
dude what if they look for it and then
like they just start watching porn hub
and stop watching us no we don't do that
cuz I've already heard that there's
there's yeah there's our faces on porn
star bodies yeah someone photoshopped
your face it'd be like they're like
[ __ ] their legs open like this yeah
you're a mother with the table you can't
yes yeah baby's gonna come out of there
but we're not sending nudes to people
guys believing it cuz I'm getting
messages saying hey Mel there's someone
on Facebook spreading your nudes I'm
like there and there's someone else
saying hey I hope you know that the
photographer that you worked with for
your nudes wants to work with me and I'm
like everything like don't accept that
I've never taken any photos professional
okay teens caught sexting each other can
now be punished under child pornography
laws I thought that was already oh [ __ ]
that's because they're under 18 so
they're spreading chung-won or was that
for under 13 like it's considered child
porn if it's
[Music]
I don't know I don't know like what's
the legal age to have sex here in the
States
18 oh what's the legal age in Austria
six pain I think really I think it
depends on the state actually but yeah
and then it depends on so like if you're
like a 17 year old then it's like how
many years under but then you can't go
past that limit like 13 or something
like that I don't know there's there's
all these [ __ ] rooms I don't know
what it is or if you have Asian parents
then the legal age is 13 I the legal age
is marriage I broke all the rules right
into the Google search federal law makes
it criminal to engage in sexual act with
another person who is between the ages
of 12 and 16 if they are at least four
years younger than you so each state
takes a different approach to the age of
consent that has ranged from 10 to 18
hmm
the age of consent starts at 10 or what
the [ __ ] and the greater some states are
very progressive I think Hawaii is like
age 14 for real yeah I remember speaking
to a lawyer at the gym and he was
talking about like yeah a couple in
Hawaii
I know alike yeah the legal age to have
sex in Hawaii is 14 maybe they just have
babies earlier in life like yeah my
nipples you know yeah because pineapples
come from Hawaii and they make you horny
yeah look at the way it's shaped it's so
[ __ ] provocative it's prickly as [ __ ]
that is don't touch me [ __ ]
bottom half is shaved pubes and the top
part is unshaved pubes
it's a pube fruit you know what I found
out today it's still like driving
driving over here this morning I found
out on the radio cuz I guess like the
topic was how how can you become fertile
like for like the woman who wants to try
to have a baby right and so like there's
like doctors and people are saying oh if
you eat pineapple like near like the
last day of your ovulation they'll help
you actually conceive and only this up
were real they're like yeah they like
googled
you asked them and they said yeah yeah
yeah and the answered my courses yeah I
just saw it on Google I'm like maybe
like but then I still feel like I sell
to google it I haven't googled it yet
but that's what they're saying and they
also said mucinex
to what it's supposed to stop congestion
or something congested yeah be congested
but when I took it one it made all my
runny nose runny boogers and so like
slimy like sticky and I would be like
pulling my boogers for nothing anyways
we're talking about ships yeah so I'd
rather talk about sex in your [ __ ]
stream yeah so it's not officially a lot
yet because they've just reported that
this bill has passed the House which it
still needs to pass a whole bunch of
other I'm gonna beetle it only the
president can veto it dude that's why
I'm the president
yes what they're saying is that this
bill it's intended to punish child
pornographers but the way that it's
written it seems like teens can also get
caught under this for sexting and it
could face at least a minimum of 15
years in prison to [ __ ] up come on
they're considering they're considering
kids that sext as child pornographers
spreaders yes because they're producing
it and distribute I am against
pedophilia a hundred percent I don't
know anyone that's for it but oh the but
I am for puppy love what I have a Romeo
and Juliet hello puppy love yeah like
popular I think I like this in the
digital era it's a part of being a youth
you gotta send a dick pic to the person
that you care about
save that no I'm serious so back in our
day it was hard right like you had to
[ __ ] get a Polaroid coach and then
pull the [ __ ] picture out and then
you go to [ __ ] her locker and then
throw it in there and it's so long so
now you could just do it immediately
you had to beg your parents to buy you a
scanner so you can email her a picture
like that phone sex I've never liked
youbut landline from the sex
I remember you put on Casey and Jojo and
then commander you go did you ever do
like you've never done phone sex
not ever it's like oh you paint a
romance novel together without any music
but you know you're should baby remember
about the boy smells so you give people
this number and you can record a voice
now voicemail in this number right and
then you play like something like Brian
McKnight or something for the first text
10 seconds and you go hey what's up you
got to do the extra deep voice that's
true because you're like 14 was so you
just hit up Joe you know so just leave
leave with your name and number and I'll
get back to you when I can and then like
the girls would do the extra Q voice you
know just thinking about you and
everything just see how you're doing you
know if you just maybe we'd like that to
school something we could go hang out
I'm free Friday wait exchange I know but
I mean like that's that's how we use the
court but then when you get on the phone
that's when you just like so what are
you wearing I just got out of a shower
oh really
if I was there right now you know
you accidentally fall and then like I
will fall on top of you and when I
magically my penis will go inside a
[ __ ] like accidentally and then like I
would really do it you know I remember
the first time a guy like what are you
wearing and I I didn't know anything
like the whole like I know it's awesome
what do you wear so innocent minded oh
really
yeah but I feel I feel like this is a
part of being a youngster so like you're
supposed to be [ __ ] each other
through digital products yeah I'd rather
have them [ __ ] each other through
digital products than [ __ ] each other in
real life but then when the pictures
leaked though that's here's my
prepubescent penis when I was 13 now
everybody's seen it since then it has
grown but then still everyone thinks
that my dick is that small with only
three pubic hairs yeah it's not fair
it's not a real representation of Who I
am that's true that's that's a good one
I would have [ __ ] up already good big
pretty happy because these are things
that now I don't ever have to say
because it's already like common
understanding so if I had because before
this law came into play like I would
have to be the one to intervene in and I
feel like [ __ ] how do I talk to my 13
year old about sending naked pictures
and there's this entire conversation
that I have to kind of create the
rulebook for but now because there is a
rulebook I can just bleh
don't do that [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] law I
told you guys before that you know I
meant I talked to Isaac about sex you've
been sending dictation imagine nobody
just you know I want him to know things
and not have be surprised or anything or
learn from his friends and get wrong
information that's what he wanted
glasses blog where we're in Versailles
and there's a statue of like a naked
girl and then Casey's like look I think
I make a girl he turns around that's
what he wanted the glass he's like
they're so [ __ ] blurry no but I know
that conversation is coming any day now
because how does he he's 9 yeah it might
not be sexual yet but he's just like I
can't wait til I slow kiss a girl no
yeah I was so cute cos like even went
like when he was in first grade he had a
little girlfriend he was like my she
held my hand there's never gonna be a
girl I can hold my head I was like oh
keep the specs going this way good thing
they went up keep the sparks going that
way yeah
oh man how about you guys can you
imagine like having that conversation no
cuz I think I'm gonna be awkward as [ __ ]
just cuz my parents never had that
conversation with me so I don't even
know how to bring it up without sounding
like a creepy at his parent I thought
the thing thing cuz my mom never talked
to me about it either at all I guess
that's how you know I ended up with the
kids are young but that's why I made it
a point I'm like okay you need to talk
to him up like that I want to be a young
grandma like when I do because if they
can't really horny and start looking all
that stuff early they're just gonna want
to start [ __ ] like when they're 12
years old and then they're just like oh
no they're gonna have a baby and I just
if I just had a baby I don't want
another baby and another baby mmm and
then you're the only one making money
because like they're 13 look anything at
a job you know what I'm gonna do let
them live on welfare divorce them at 13
you can do it at the courts yeah you
wanna be a [ __ ] you want to be a
geezer go off
run along into the world now go anyway
or you could a book I'm a roll-on like
dr. Phil and then they turn into
millionaires manager see you know how to
exploit children I just see them as a
burden so I kick them away easy way to
come melena Matt's gonna happen I've got
to think more like you guys man how do
you use your children as ranch hands
who's you guys you I never said anything
but you smiled and you said that's my
husband
it was more like I can't believe that's
my husband
what do you mean that's what happened to
[ __ ] know what the owner name is how
about that yeah cash me outside she was
a troublemaker
yeah went on dr. Phil blew the [ __ ] up
the beef between her and her mom
all of a sudden disappeared the mom is
now the manager and bam all you gotta do
is be very trashy abuse your children
argue with them like they're your equal
and it'll be perfect you could bring
them on a talk show WI half you know she
just hanging on my spine stuff oh and
they got to act like they're hella
ghetto they gotta act like they're hella
ghetto yeah from a ghetto from a place
you never even heard of yep yeah like
the ghetto ass place in Wisconsin yeah
what all your neighbors are just trailer
trash but they think that they're black
people I'm beating their ass for sure I
can't even take it to that level I don't
have that discipline I hope you guys
enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]
[Music]